all right it is time for this week's pet
project amy lee joins us from nspca she
brought along someone who needs a safe
and good home we're talking about cinder
today
yes this is cinder it's the cutest
little thing
she is a six year old female and she's
just the sweetest little pity she's
about 45 pounds
and she's so lovable so friendly she
gets along with
everybody and she just wants a loving
home and we've just discovered that she
kind of does little tricks
um we just discovered that which is kind
of fun when we have dogs that you know
that we bring in and we get to know and
she kind of does
a little high five which is great can
you do you think she'll perform on
camera and it's live tv
i'm gonna have to i have to tell you i
had a prize at my desk and i'm just
being totally honest with you and
thing she likes is a no-no but cinder
keeps it
can you use it please
well she kind of did it but at least she
sat on command that was very good
oh she does you know what she gets along
with other dogs with the meet and greet
um kids six and up just because you know
she just a little bit of her size but
other than that she's kind of a jab i
mean she really is so sweet
yeah so and if folks aren't looking for
a 45 pounder you have all sorts of
animals
that need a good home right absolutely
just check our website at nevadaspca.org
you know
the animals are always changing a lot of
dogs get adopted a lot of cats get
adopted so you have to
just check it and make sure what you see
you know that you're interested in and
we'll talk to you more about it at the
shelter
all right amy thanks so much good to see
you thanks
if you are interested in adopting sender
or any pet you can go to
nevadaspca.org or call that phone number
to make an appointment go visit these
animals 702-873-7722